we're back with some analysis of a very
interesting thought-provoking and
controversial conversation taking place
on twitter over the last several days
and it was uh started by this guy adam
davidson who
has about 130 000 twitter followers and
so he's got quite a bit of play and
clout and as you can see here's the
tweets he writes dear academia i
understand that citing others work is
crucial to you but writing clearly
powerfully for a broad audience is also
crucial it is very hard to write
compellingly while also constantly
citing research and this is part of a
thread as you can see
he followed that up by saying
good writers obsess about creating a
narrative impact compelling scenes
characters etc
constantly citing where each distinct
idea comes from makes it impossible to
build a fluid narrative that readers can
get lost in
i'm not arguing writers should never
cite of course not i'm just saying
there's a real trade-off between citing
and
narrative
journalists will almost always be on the
side of narrative academics on the side
of citing
this is partly why academic writing is
so often boring unreadable to a
layperson and has such little impact so
shots across the boughs
subtweeting basically all of academia
and let's see what happens
next so there's a lot of good responses
here these are all taken from the
massive
thread you can say
good journalism writing is not
necessarily at odds with citation and
citation need not interrupt narrative in
fact good citation should add to the
narrative contextualize it and give
resources to the reader another if your
citation breaks your storytelling you're
not using the appropriate citation
method there's absolutely no need for
them to break the narrative another one
simply not true you can write the most
fascinating paragraph in the universe
and still tell people where ideas or
data come from
then it starts getting very interesting
do you not understand how incredibly
easy it is to cite through hyperlink
online without losing the threat of your
narrative academics do it all the time
when we write for a popular audience and
then it starts to get you know really
good
imagine if someone invented a system
where you could at no cost reference
anything you like without in any way
interrupting the flow of prose to make
if you will a web of links seems like
something which might be useful and this
is pointing out the fact that as the
next tweet says
this isn't the 80s generating citations
and footnotes is the easiest thing ever
it's not exciting neither is getting
your hard work stolen by someone else
deal and this is referencing what's
going on which is concerns about not
citing people
as a way of appropriating their hard
work then finally online at least you
can have it both ways use text with
links to source citations more work but
fits any writing style
for that matter the end the footnotes
made into endnotes are pretty
non-intrusive in any case a candid
argument might be my audience doesn't
care and so all these people are
pointing out that you know in response
to the original text or original tweet
by adam davidson
you know this is kind of a
a lazy way of going about things if you
want to cite it's super easy so why
should we be discouraging people from
doing that
let's look at the next set of tweets and
this is where the academics strike back
my phd is in communication i'm a
broadcaster researching journalism i
write for academics and the public for
print and broadcast
crediting sources doesn't crumble a
compelling narrative it introduces
characters credibility and humility
citation styles vary they don't vanish
this is directly targeting uh the the
original post saying
you can have all these things and you
don't need to pose them to citation
here's another good to tweet one i
mostly disagree it's possible to include
citations in a way that breaks up the
narrative however simply using footnotes
solves that problem if anything when
doing detailed technical journalism
journalists could learn from academics
it's also worth saying that if you think
that the source is being cited are
separate from the narrative of academic
work you don't understand academic work
the practice of including author name
when citing is because it matters whose
version of an idea you are thinking with
here's another one nah man this is a
lazy argument on multiple levels plenty
of academic writers are also good
writers who obsess over impact and flow
and yet somehow also find ways to cite
their sources with distracting from
their narrative this is even easier with
hyperlinks try harder
another good point there are good
academic writers and bad ones the
difference isn't in the number of
sources they cite
another one why are you assuming
academics wouldn't like to write for a
broader audience there are gatekeepers
preventing many talented professional
scholars from doing this
you apparently don't know much about the
writing industry and then finally these
two things are not mutually exclusive
not talking to academics who have
studied the topic for years or using
their work selectively in service of a
more streamlined narrative
leads to dangerous intellectual laziness
on the part of journal journals
journalists
allah malcolm gladwell and you know he's
kind of a poster boy for doing shoddy
sloppy work like that
and so you know this is the academics
pointing out that this guy's getting the
academic side wrong and then we can look
at um the more popular side
it really isn't difficult to write
compelling and engaging text while
appropriately citing where ideas come
from and frankly if you can't do it
maybe you have no business writing
anything non-fiction plagiarism is
plagiarism bestie
another good response to this
that's a lazy answer journalism often
cites sources within the text of the
piece journalism even site sources when
the source is confidential there is a
consistent methodology to provide
background to information and journalism
not doing so is inherently
suspect
another good one
it's very hard to write compellingly
while also constantly citing research
yeah writing well is hard it takes work
that's why they're paying you to do it
if you can't tell your your story with
sources you're not a responsible scholar
or
journalist
and then finally
what journalism doesn't give credit to
sources doesn't hyperlink a name a
breaking story doesn't spell out
evidence under girding a story or
involve rigorous fact checking
good narratives flesh out a story and
reveal the foundation a story is built
upon so here we were seeing people
saying listen buddy you're not even
getting journalism right or popular
writing right and uh you know this is a
little bit suspect there's a little bit
more that's being said about this this
is quite good and here we start getting
to
uh some some other important aspects
the issue isn't writing powerfully
clearly for a broad audience which
academics do all the time anyway the
issue is journalists acting like they've
broken new ground or discovered
something new that historians have known
for literal decades a big big problem
not only for the pieces that are being
you know defended or referenced
in this case by adam davidson but you
know in a lot of other cases as well
stop with the excuses you can give
credit as simple as quote this is a fact
that for years has been exhaustively
researched by black and caribbean
historians but largely ignored by
mainstream media until today i think
it's a good point and then here's
another good one i know it's possible to
write clearly and compellingly for
laymen while still citing sources
because checks notes
black public intellectuals have done it
for at least a century because black
folk survival depends on it
then here's another
good one
journalists find it impossible to write
compelling prose while being
intellectually honest and transparent
is not the rousing defense of the new
york times that you think it is
i mean claiming that something is
impossible to do right when other people
are doing it right um there's something
disingenuous
finally there's a big difference between
not letting citations interrupt
narrative flow and falsely claiming to
have done original research by
plagiarizing from your own sources
that is a great point and then
here we get to an interesting case study
i just scrolled through todd hissy coats
the case for reparations in 10 minutes i
found 18 in-text citations of historians
sociologists and others
it's not hard so this is a prime example
of
high-impact uh you know well-informed
journalism that actually cites its
sources
totally going against davidson's claim
that you can't do that kind of writing
and be effective
and then somebody wrote as a joke but
imagine how broad an audience he could
have reached and how much a claim he
would have gotten from the profession if
he hadn't bothered with all that
referencing another person pointed out
coates understands that readers benefit
from in-text bibliography access to
further readings is a great service so
as opposed to what davidson was was you
know putting forth as what popular
writing and journalistic writing needs
to look like tony heasy coates is
not treating his uh readers like
children who can't handle
being given access to information
then we started getting into some very
interesting
more
back and forth discussion so
sarah pecko wrote to adam davidson
respectfully disagree and then adam
fell into his own pit by saying can you
point to examples where a compelling
narrative has lots of citations
and you know predictably a lot of people
picked up on the hypocrisy here
citing is overrated can you cite some
examples another person wrote you're
asking for a citation to prove citations
are overrated
um another wrote i'm sorry you want
someone to cite their sources citations
make for bad tweets
another person wrote i wouldn't want to
disrupt the narrative arc of this tweet
by citing anything i might lose a reader
and another one as soon as you point to
examples of work that doesn't cite it
sources that isn't plagiarism they're
throwing it back in davidson's lap and
then finally somebody said
hey
wikipedia it's probably the most
universally read and most approachable
entry point for lay people into any
complex topic guess what it has
footnotes at the bottom of every page
with citations for everything so you
know davidson uh you know kind of
stepped in it in that and there are a
few other great responses somebody just
posted a picture of howard sends a
people his people's history of the
united states
lots of citations in that one and yet
you've got something that's quite
accessible and you know did have a lot
of
impact
here's another good one pretty easy to
provide a note section that doesn't
interrupt flow various forms exist
poland's omnivores dilemma
scots against the grain
diamonds gun germs and steel etc etc as
for journalism and print it can be tough
but hyperlinks make it easy i do it all
the time in my non-academic journalism
even better tell the story via the
sources
here's another one most any non-fiction
book i've read has contained copious
amounts of citations and plenty were
really good reads some listed sources at
the bottom of a page with little
unobtrusive footnotes
one i have on hand the pirates it's
about jewish pirates has a bibliography
and there are more citation styles than
mla modern languages association which
is what you must be thinking of if you
think citing sources will somehow make
the writing more difficult use chicago
style or include a list of sources at
the bottom of an article so again what
we're seeing in these responses is that
davidson
you know perhaps he does know these
things but he displayed himself as
somebody who doesn't really understand
the basics of citation and how it can be
worked into writing
there was another thing that people
targeted him for as well and i think
that this is
quite fair here somebody wrote uh isn't
it ironic when someone trying to teach
us boring academics what good writing is
gets ratioed for bad social media
writing and here's some of the ratioing
taking place
dear journalism thank you for this
critique which points to no specific
academic writing of any kind to anchor
its comments thereby unironically
proving the necessity for citations the
patronizing tone is also a nice touch
your friend academia
and then you know the statement itself
gets targeted in the sentence by
davidson and i quote but writing clearly
comma powerfully comma for a broad
audience is comma also comma crucial i
count no less than four unnecessary
commas that are as much of a distraction
as comic sans in a keynote address
and somebody else wrote
but writing clearly come a powerful a
comma for a broad audience is comma also
comma crucial
is this clear writing
good points i think
then we start getting into some other
really um you know substantive critiques
uh
here's a another
this is a reference to the the piece
that that essentially provoked this
which uh davidson didn't actually
mention in his tweets hopefully this
isn't the actual response to the fact
that the new york times piece on haiti
ripped off direct quotes findings
archival research from haitian academics
and activists while only choosing to
cite white men who didn't actually
further any of the analysis in the piece
and she goes on and says it's
interesting seeing this discussion when
non-white people have to jump through
hoops to show rigor in sight so that
they won't be mislabeled as ripping off
work from some vague white academic
they've never heard of or read i say
this is someone who also writes for the
public and still time finds time to cite
it's interesting who and what
publication bodies citation exemptions
are always extended to for academics and
if we go down a little bit further in my
opinion the piece isn't doing its job if
a bunch of white people in defense of a
piece about theft and the public
historical plus present narratives of
downplaying that theft of haiti and
haitians are now justifying
why it's okay that the peace
is engaged in further haitian theft
these are you know i think very solid
points that are being made and you know
continuing on here's another good set of
tweets
let me see if i have this right first
black stories ignored by press black
historians do their work
second press realizes there's profit and
black stories
third press can't give credit to black
historians because
it doesn't make for pretty sentences
she goes on and says some people clearly
don't read enough scholarship to know
that sometimes the citation is a central
piece of the storytelling and this is
especially true in black tradition our
ancestors are compelling and have
narrative impact
and then she goes on she's got a great
take here can you imagine what these
people would say about the torah no way
this book can have impact too many lists
too many characters not enough narrative
impact through well-crafted
sentences
entirely on point there
now
there's also some that were you know
speculating about the motives here i'm
not going to say that i endorse these
necessarily but
i think these are quite good
um in in terms of like thinking about
what's happening clout chasing new
yorker magazine is in his bio he's still
listed as a contributing writer but it
doesn't look like he's employed by the
magazine he owns a company wait for it
masterful storytelling the thread is a
bid for attention
for his company a shameless would be in
quotes master
another says i've got to say writing
clearly powerfully and irresponsibly for
a broad audience is a well-known way to
build a personal brand while making the
world worse journalists should think on
this and then finally
somebody else has fixed this thread for
you erasing everything after
i understand that sightings others work
is crucial which you know does improve
upon it
uh we have another
set of interesting things here where
there's also a response by adam davidson
if you're an academic looking for a
career ending plagiarism scandal follow
adam's advice and then adam writes do
you think i'm suggesting this for
academics you can't be that obtuse i am
simply observing there are different
values in journalism and academia and
there are trade-offs between them and
then you know people pointed out dude
you literally open with dear academia
and then you know somebody else who
pointed that you started with dear
academia davidson says and i went on to
address how academia speaks to
journalists and somebody else pointed
out no you didn't or at least that idea
is not retrievable from this thread
maybe if you'd cited the topic that
spurred you to start this thread it
would have been clear what you're
talking about so you know pointing out
why
citation can often be quite helpful
uh at least for establishing context in
clear writing
another says when you begin with dear
academia those who err on the side of
the clarity you espouse may legitimately
think you're discussing academic
discourse
one thing i've picked up in journalism
and academia is that calling your
audience obtuse
might not help them hear you any better
another point out i think in this case
it's pretty difficult to tell what your
point was the way the tweets were
written seemed to suggest criticism of
how academics write and a case for
making it better and more impactful the
writing you're writing davidson isn't
clear
and then you know here's a final one you
start your thread with dear academia and
you're saying others should write more
clearly
so
there are um
several other things that i think are
quite interesting in the conversation
this is a bit of a side note but it's
good to bring this to a close with this
here's another genre
and you know the tweet says i'll concede
your point for podcasting citing
material in the middle of a linear
spoken string of language is tough
but between hyperlinks and endnotes
there are plenty of non-linear ways to
credit people in prose without
sacrificing narrative flow and this
started a good conversation
somebody else wrote my favorite
podcasters cite their sources in the
episode descriptions if not in the
narration
mike duncan and joe
kasabian list sources in their narration
smoothly unethical [ __ ] are
apparently above citations and then the
original poster totally citation needs
to happen there too in the descriptions
are allowed at the end of the podcast
episode as a bare minimum it's just
trickier to cite authors book titles
especially if there's several in the
flow of the delivery but people out
there still do it well then somebody
else points out signal phrases exist and
here's a good example in fact according
to scholar of blah blah so and so and
the response for sure i'm thinking more
if somebody has really done their
homework and would like to list a lot of
sources as historians often do in
footnotes most of the time though it's a
reasonable expectation so there's a good
discussion here about how this you know
would apply in a different format that
of podcasts
we can also talk about youtube videos
and this is a good one too
no there's no conflict between citations
and compelling content youtubers
do it every single day with videos all
the time
it's not hard to maintain basic
intellectual honesty and to assume that
citing work costs something is
disingenuous at best which started then
another conversation
considering youtube is a video format
you can always cite sources as text on
the video instead of addressing it
verbally which could break the flow so i
don't know if that's a fair comparison
but even then most academic texts i've
had to read never felt stilted at all
when citing references then the original
poster writing has more advantages
footnotes asides and more importantly
the one-off acknowledge statement like
while others have done such and such
let's go further by doing such and such
riddled with hyperlinks and then the
person also continues i'm pretty sure
most of that can be accomplished in a
similar manner in a video foot format
but yeah i get the point there really is
no excuse after all on not being able to
do so
in
writing my final thoughts you know
obviously i think this academic versus
journalistic thing is is a silly
dichotomy
plenty of academics know how to do
things within the popular sphere and you
know there's many ways to write or to do
other
formats accessibly
and to incorporate a proper citation of
sources while you're doing so i'm very
sympathetic to the idea that
it does demand work but that's the work
that you ought to be doing whether
you're a journalist a pr person
somebody who's just tweeting
or you know an academic or a public
scholar
you know you're you're supposed to do
the work rather than make excuses for
why people don't do the work
and you know this is something i think
we do want to hold the line on so that
is it for this conversation i'm sure
people have plenty of comments of their
own that they would like to make
about this very interesting twitter
conversation
and we'll leave it at that
you